Was ist das für ein overlay was wollen die von mir?
Was das
Was alter twitch
Ihr wollt mir nicht ernsthaft erzählen ich muss mich jetzt einloggen damit ich den chat sehen kann oder
Alter ist das euer ernst ja klar handy nummer
Ist das wirklich was soll der scheiß mann
Was soll denn dieser kack alter
Was ist das für eine scheiße was haben sie sich da wieder ausgedacht mann was ist das denn
Ich ich bin absichtlich nicht in meinem streaming account eingeloggt das ist pur
Warum kann ich das regt mich das regt mich jetzt mal richtig auf alter
Geht dann geht er geht dann
Das mal kurz was testen ok das funktioniert noch
Ok wenn man anonymen aha jebaited jebaited
Out out played
It's out played
Outdated overrated jebaited now we out played it
Keine ahnung
Es aber stimmt meiner sound settings nicht sack doch stimmt alles
Ich habe das video von ihm auch geguckt ich habe das video von ihm auch geguckt
Also mit der bürste mit der bürste bürste bräuchte ich vielleicht noch ich mache das aktuell mit den händen drauf
und reibt auch so ein bisschen ein den schaum
aber das ist
Wahrscheinlich nicht der weißheitsletzter schluss
Was ist denn in dem modus großartig anders ich glaube ich glaube ich weiß was großartig anders ist
Die die erkennen vielleicht ob man
Wobei eigentlich kann man nicht richtig inkognito modus erkennen
Was auch immer zumindest ich werde mich nicht beschweren es funktioniert so warte mal lass mal lass mal was ausprobieren
Ne hier hier nervter
Wartet mal können wir den können wir den
Auch auspländen
Aber jetzt hat chat inaktiv der connectet sich gar nicht moment
Moment moment und jetzt müssen wir noch irgendwie das ob er das aber shit wir lassen einfach den offen und gut ist
Ja
Ja da weiß wovon auch spricht
Ich sag euch wie es hätte der fabian beauty videos gemacht oder hätte ein bisschen weiter gemacht was diese videos angeht ohne scheiß der fabian wir heute
der größte
männliche beziehungsweise ja weiß ich weil es ja nicht nur männer content machen als möglich
männliche beauty youtuber auf
youtube ja
hätte weiter gemacht
Weil der fabian hat einen vorteil als der frazier der hat einen vorteil gegenüber diesen ganzen anderen noobs
Der fabian hat das die optik dafür ja also dem der sieht gut aus der verkauft das auch gut und vor allem
Siehst du an ihm selbst dass es funktioniert
Und der hat halt auch noch wovon er spricht da was die ganzen an ganzen beauty noobs alle nicht haben
Ja
Gatschi-gasm so sieht es aus
Moment moment meine warum gehen meine emotes denn hier gerade nicht
Moment extensions die muss man die muss man white listen
Erweiterungen
Ffz
Details im incognito modus zulassen machen wir
Ja das aber das noch mal kurz probieren
Gatschi
hyper
Ne geht nicht warum nicht
Ach fack alder weil oh shit resette sich im cognito modus auch die settings von ffz
Ich hoffe nicht
Ok ok testen wir noch mal shit alder nein ok incognito modus ist nicht wirklich zu gebrauchen
Aber
Wisst ihr also nicht diese gängelung nervt mich schon wieder extrem ja
Edons wir machen
Aber habe ich das sonst immer an
aktivieren aktivieren aktivieren so muss man aktivieren aktivieren
Aktivieren
Stopp passt so das braucht man gar nicht alles
Egal so ich hoffe ich hoffe dass das checkt jetzt jetzt jetzt funktioniert es auch
Meine güte hast du kein hast du kein backup für die einstellung
Das ist eine gute idee das könnten wir tatsächlich moment wollen das können wir tatsächlich beobachten
Moment wollen das kann man tatsächlich probieren das ist das ist eine gute idee das lasst mal kurz hier probieren hopp up chat
Aller man darf noch nicht mal den button anklicken ich raste aus
Ok moment easy
Ich war schneller ich war schneller
Wie macht man hier den export
Weiß jemand backup and restore
safe
backup
So und jetzt gehen wir hier rein five hat time
Jetzt gehen wir hier rein das kann ich einfach einmal am anfang vom stream machen
sichern und wieder herstellung sicherung wieder herstellen
downloads ffz settings
Eats easy kann man nur zu sagen
Easy easy easy easy easy easy
Macht überhaupt kein unterschied was es ist kann auch bei der twitch tv sein das plugin ist vollkommen egal
Ja ich könnte irgendeinen user script machen übrigens das was wir gebaut haben für meinen access point mit dem hinzufügen von
Dynamic ps cars also quasi wlan password pro user
Endlich pro user pro gerät so dass man nicht immer ein ein wlan password für alles braucht was ziemlich sagt das benutze ich mittlerweile
Regelmäßig wir haben hier so was erstellt wo man das im web interface ordentlich machen kann richtig nice
Ich habe jetzt schon ein ich habe es neue laptop für die arbeit ist neue handy das neue ipad alles mögliche darüber eingerichtet
Mit jubla geht das bestimmt easy weg
ne also
Zumindest zumindest
Zumindest die fault mäßig nicht weil jubla ist ja an
Ja, aber das ist wirklich echt hängen geblieben hier mit dem dass das ist richtig nervig alda
Kurz bisschen leiser machen
Das hier geht bestimmt okay
Das das mal ausprobieren
Das geht aber da ist kein dark theme und
Jetzt ist mein
Leute aber da funktioniert der rest nicht dass die seite pro pro broken af
Diese seite reagiert nicht
What
Alla chrome
Jetzt jetzt habe ich anklicken ok habe ich denn jetzt hier sticht meine ffz settings nimmt er die jetzt mit
Ich glaube schon oder
Chat aussehen wie macht man denn die farbe jetzt hier leute ich bin komplett plan wie stellt man hier überhaupt die farbe vom chat ein
Ich ich habe das einmal eingestellt vor drei jahren mann was weiß ich wie das jetzt funktioniert hat
Ach scheiß drauf wir lassen es einfach so geht ja auch
Ich meine es ist auch alles alles drinne
Übrigens habt ihr schon gesehen wobei ich weiß gar nicht ob das schon da ist
Das ist jetzt dass die dass die suche im archiv noch mehr play singly fast ist als ohnehin schon
Die ist die ist extrem lieb play singly fast written in rust
Und es gibt neue pepo bilder gibt sogar echt ein paar sachen die euch zeichnen
Doch ist er doch da ist er doch
Da ist er doch
Also es ist noch es ist noch mehr es ist noch mehr play singly fast
Und es gibt neue pepo bilder gibt es sogar echt ein paar sachen die euch zeigen können
Es gibt richtig nice pepo bilder ich weiß ich ob der regt man ist der regt man da
Willen wir eigentlich hab ihn schon gesehen irgendjemand nicht ich hab nicht habe ich nicht doch ist er doch da ist er doch
Guck wenn ich nach kackel suche bähm wobei ist es überhaupt schon drinne. Oh guck mal leute man kann jetzt sogar suchen nach
Datum das auch neugär
Richtig richtig high IQ jetzt das archiv was vorher schon aber jetzt ist absolut heißt IQ aber es geht immer noch pro es geht immer noch
mehr ja
Probra wo willst du ja pro prime sub ein eq punkt für alle das dumme daran ist nur
Wenn das ab ausläuft ist es auch wieder weg
Das heißt man muss schon gucken dass man da irgendwie am bald bleibt außerdem gibt es cooles ab batches und sub emotes
und alles mögliche
Das heißt wenn es euch danach ist und ihr kein bock habt dass besus dass besus euren prime sub quasi in die eigene tasche steckt
Da können jetzt präzisen manchmal ist meine irgendwie arschlange ok
cache gedürt vielleicht
Es gibt neue pepo bilder die muss ich euch gleich mal zeigen aber erst mal chat lesen
Face gesicht du bist auch schon lange am start
Ich habe es nicht durchgängig gesagt das weiß ich aber der name der kommt mir bekannt vor den habe ich mir irgendwie generne
generne gemerkt
Du schreibst nicht viel ich weiß aber der name kommt mir bekannt vor das habe ich mir irgendwie gemerkt weil falls irgendwie so
Irgendwie face gesicht ist irgendwie kann man sich irgendwie gut merken
Und falls ihr bei mir nicht sammeln wollt ist auch nicht schlimm
Aber sappt wenigstens irgendwo mit eurem prime sub anstatt sie zu verschenken falls ihr überhaupt amazon prime habt wenn ihr kein prima
Kann ich der prime sub auch nicht verfallen
Loter noch sein geschehen für den sub
Ich bin eher ein lockerer macht ja nix wie war die arbeit
Leute also
Ich sage ich sage jetzt was könnte so könnte sogar sein dass da leute von der arbeit zugucken ich wurde ja schon
mehrfach mehrfach
geleakt
One finger mehr dankeschön für den sub also ich sage euch jetzt mal was zur neuen arbeit
Eins ich sage euch was gutes und was was mir nicht so gut gefällt also
Das erste was ich richtig gut finde was auch richtiger kontrast zum letzten arbeitgeber ist
Die atmosphäre ist deutlich netter so untereinander auch klar das wird nicht überall so sein
Gibt bestimmt auch ein paar leute die sind ätzend aber ich rede nicht ich rede jetzt nicht nur von meinem team ja weil mit meinem team was
Beim alten arbeitgeber auch vollkommen in ordnung. Ne ich meine insgesamt ich bin jetzt ja direkt von tag 1 in so einem komischen
Cloud kubernetes projekt mit am start was ich eigentlich ganz cool finde es wäre nur es wäre nur deutlich cooler wenn man auch ein bisschen mehr machen
könne
Aber der umgang mit den leuten untereinander ist deutlich netter ich war am dienstag
Wahrscheinlich keine ahnung wie anfangen der woche war ich in so einer sprint review planungs runde das ging irgendwie zwei stunden
Aber an alle möglichen leute dabei von technik bis
Verantwortliche bis
Projektleiter und sowas muss man ohne scheißer
Der der umgang untereinander ist deutlich netter als noch bei meinem alten arbeitgeber das finde ich finde ich finde ich wirklich sehr gut
Und ich danke schön danke schön für den sub ich muss gleich hier oben noch was lesen ich habe hier war noch ein paar sachen
So also das ist das erste finde ich wirklich richtig nice
Ich weiß
Anderen sachen mal gucken
Also das gefällt mir das gefällt mir wirklich gut das ist auch schon echt ein riesen vorteil wenn du nicht standardmäßig davon ausgehen musst alter
Der andere geht jetzt eh gleich auf den sack ne
Tatsächlich nicht
Das war bisher immer wirklich sehr nett untereinander der umgang mit den leuten auch
Also kann man nichts sagen das ist schon mal nice also die scheinen sich auch echt leute auszusuchen die sozial ein bisschen
Nicht die größten spasten sind aber
Also das ist schon das finde ich schon mal sehr nice
Was mir nicht so gut gefällt es kann durchaus sein dass das
Es wird nicht gewöhnungssache sein aber vielleicht muss man gucken also eine sache der meeting anteil ist auch wieder unsinnig hoch
Ich mache also die einzige zeit am tag wo ich wirklich ordentlich was mache
Ist ungefähr von sieben uhr bis neun uhr 30 weil da sind noch keine meetings und dann geht es los
Mit mit einem daily dort dann irgendwie teamrunde hier dann kommt irgendwie eine weitere planung da und im prinzip
Ich kann es euch ich kann es euch mal
Ach miss ich habe das handy gar nicht hier wo ich jetzt den kalender gucken kann es wird viel zu viel gemietet
Aber die meisten meeting sind auch nicht sonderlich sinnvoll
Also es wird
Es wird viel zu viel gemietet
und insgesamt
Das ist gut das ist jetzt kein gut das ist jetzt weder weder plus plus minus null zu meinem alten arbeitgeber weil da haben wir auch viel unsinnig gemietet
Was mich aber nach wie vor nervt ist dieses ultra
Restriktive gut meine haben auflagen die können sich auch nicht immer ausdenken aber ok
ultra restriktiv aber auch teilweise
extrem übertrieben so dass es schon wieder nicht richtig zu benutzen ist somit kisten komplett ohne internetverbindung wo man nicht mal ein ordentliches
command line tools drauf machen kann und
dass man auch bei jedem furz
zu fünf anderen teams rennen muss
Obwohl man auf der anderen seite agil sein will also ist passt irgendwie das passt nicht so ganz
Also ich glaube das ist der sache dass aber der sache geschuldet dass es eben
Den riesengroßer laden ist und die halt bis vor kurzem auch noch sehr oldschool unterwegs waren das sieht man auch dort ja
Also wieder die luxe kisten administriert werden das ist nicht schlecht aber das ist wirklich äußerst äußerst oldschool auch wie das wie das gemacht ist
Und wenn man sich die protokolle anguckt und sowas alles mit fünf durchschlägen und so also
Also sinnbildlich gesprochen wir machen nicht wirklich fünf kopien davon aber
Also das ist schon das ist schon sehr sehr oldschool feeling in vielen in vielen bereichen
In dem cloud projekt wo ich bin ist es halt anders die wollen tatsächlich modern sein können es aber nicht so hundertprozentig einfach
Weil das wahrscheinlich eines der ersten dinger ist wo sie so wirklich auch probieren mal agil zu sein mit
Übergreifen über teams das beim projekt die leute mitarbeiten mitarbeiten ohne immer über fünf
Hierarchie eben den gehen zu müssen das klappt noch nicht so richtig gut weil
Es ist es ist halt unterm strich immer noch so
Also man muss ehe wovon fünf an fünf stellen fragen ob man was machen darf und aber
Das könnte ich mir tatsächlich vorstellen dass das dadurch dass die jetzt quasi erst anfangen so richtig versuchen modern zu sein
Dass ich das tatsächlich verbessern in den nächsten jahren
Da habe ich tatsächlich begründete annahme dazu dass es so sein wird weil man sieht jetzt schon dass das in diesem projekt obwohl das vorher dinosaurier modus war
Nicht nur gesagt wird wir wollen agil sein sondern was zumindest
Versucht man schafft es noch nicht so direkt in dem gesamten umfeld dieses dieses riesen riesen laden das richtig richtig umzusetzen
Richtig umzusetzen aber man will als man sagt nicht nur dass man es machen will man will das auch
Das ist ein riesen unterschied zu dem wo ich vorher war bei dem laden die haben mich immer nur gesagt sie wollen das und dann wollten
Sie es doch nicht wenn es darum geht was zu machen
Ja so sieht es aus
Ach ja und eine sache die mir auch tatsächlich ein bisschen auf den keks geht ist die haben so den den hang dazu
Meetings übelst spät einzuladen die wollten ernsthaft montag einladen 16 bis 18 uhr ich bin da morgens losgefahren
Ich kann doch nicht
12 stunden rum hocken oder wie also
Das funktioniert nicht ich habe jetzt ich habe jetzt bei mir in kalender eingetragen dass ich ab 15 30
Weg bin ich meine ich bin zwar meistens erst 16 uhr weg aber dass keiner noch irgendwelche meetings einlädt und
Eine sache ist ganz cool ich bin im projekt noch mit jemand anderem zusammen der ist relativ spät da der ist meistens
Erst einmal nur 30 da und ich bin schon am sieben da oder teilweise kurz vor sieben dann passt das ich bin vormittags
am starten der ist noch nachmittags länger am start
Aber trotzdem ich meine du kannst doch nicht ernsthaft meetings ansetzen am ende des arbeitstages
Von zwei stunden länge und dann irgendwie erwarten da ist noch jemand wirklich aufmerksam im kopf dabei wie soll das funktionieren
Funktionieren
Also ich werde die in zukunft wahrscheinlich dann auch ab nächster woche jetzt habe ich ja konstant diesen blocktermin ab 15 30 auch
ich werde zwar nicht kommentarlos ablehnen aber
Ich werde ich werde eine antwort schreiben dass ich um die uhrzeit nicht mehr da bin
Sollen sie dann machen
Ja tom schreibt gerade meine erste arch installation hinter mir mal einfach den ganzen networkrahmen übersprungen und gewonnen
Warum packen wir nicht in die jahre da musste tatsächlich aufpassen
Die einfachste variante bei der arch installation netzwerk zu machen ist tatsächlich
Der ich lese mal der nupe modus
Lass sind lasst das ding im network manager installieren
Da musst du dich eigentlich um gar nichts kümmern solange du dhcp hast im netzwerk ist gar kein gar kein problem
Solange du dhcp hast im netzwerk ist gar kein gar kein problem
Ja, wir gucken uns gleich deine bildchen an
Ich finde ich schon mal extrem
Kann ich schon mal
falsches emote wo ist es denn
Wtf hier da jetzt habe ich
Das ist ein feature das ist das ist weil die written in rust sind wenn die immer so schnell werden könnten sie in zukunft ja nichts mal verbessern
Verstehst die bauen absichtlich ab und zu delays ein dass die bei der nächsten version schreiben können
performance optimization
optimisatio optimierung
Wie gefällt es dir denn auf der neuen arbeit also für
Vor circa 17 1 halb sekunden habe ich das ausführlich erzählt
Ich weiß dass ich ob das jetzt alle paar minuten noch mal erzählen soll heute doch ich erzählte ich erzählte ok ok wir machen
Jetzt wir machen jetzt was wir waren jetzt was ich erzähle es maximal einmal alle halbe stunde
Oder
Einer der es wirklich genau wissen will
nur mit prime sub
Oder ihr müsst eine halbe stunde da bleiben
Ok
Ja ja sehr neues hat jemand von euch einen unify switch und weiß wie man finde es wahrscheinlich auf unify zu finden
Nein habe ich nicht aber ich habe was ähnliches ich habe den ubiquity switch allerdings ein ubiquity ein ubiquity edge switch
das ist
Ne ernsthaft
Ok ich erzähle es gleich noch mal die kurz die kurzfassung aber die kurzfassung also
Ich habe den edge switch der hat das problem nicht mit sich zu unify zu finden das ist eigentlich eine mega krasse taktik irgendwie
prime subs zu baiten oder
Man muss einfach so tun als muss man dann was machen wo man gar keinen bock drauf hat und dann
Dann hat man sogar den vorteil leute die dich nicht leiden können die sammeln dann auch
Weil die denken dann du musst was machen worauf du keinen bock hast
Das ist quasi so hey
Das ist quasi so hate subbing falls es so was gibt
Eigentlich das ist eigentlich richtig six hat das so zu machen da reicht feifert schon einmal für ich gehe jetzt
Ich ich sage gleich was dazu ich gehe trotzdem an den chat durch sonst vergesse ich es wieder
Leute die dir nicht die dich nicht leiden können hören die überhaupt zu hier du wirst es nicht glauben ich habe letztens
Ich kann ich kann dir gar nicht mehr sagen in welchem kontext ich ich weiß nicht ob ich was gelesen habe ob ich es
Irgendwo in dem stream gehört habe oder ich kriege es nicht mehr zusammen zumindest gibt es bei jedem streamer
Wahrscheinlich ist das jetzt irgendwie wissenschaftliche studier oder so gewesen wie gesagt ich weiß nicht mehr woher
Deswegen muster googelt aber ich habe letztens irgendwo aufgeschnappt dass es bei jedem streamer eine
Nicht so unterschätzende anzahl an
Hate
Viewern gibt die eigentlich nur da sind
Um zu gucken ob er irgendwas verkackt
Und im zweifelsfall
Oder hate watcher ja und wenn er was verkackt es sofort zu klippen es sofort zu posten
Sofort nvidia shadowplay anzumachen falls er die falls er die dinge löscht
Sofort nvidia shadowplay anzumachen falls er die falls er die dinge löscht und es dann zu reporten und die
war die die gucken dann wirklich zu die streams
Weil sie den typ nicht abkönnen nur um ihm eins rein zu wirken wenn er mal kacke baut
und
Wie gesagt ich weiß nicht mal wo ich das aufgeschnappt habe es noch gar nicht so lange her aber es geht jetzt geht mal in euch
Selbst wenn ich jetzt die quelle nicht weiß
So unwahrscheinlich beziehungsweise weit hergeholt klingt das doch gar nicht es gibt doch immer so leute
Ja gibt es immer so leute ich habe gerade noch eine gehaltsabrechnung gekriegt vom alten arbeitgeber ich muss da mal kurz rein
lurken
Ob die es hinbekommen haben
Mit meinen urlaubstagen das richtig zu verrechnen ich habe zwar jetzt eine
Bescheinigung ach nee
Das ist die lohnsteuerbescheinigung 2023 das ist gar nicht die abrechnung da dann nicht da nicht da nicht
Das gute ist die artschgruppe die ist wirklich nice da hat aber noch keiner was geschrieben drin
Du hast auch immer wir stehst vor neun auf warum denn auch nicht
Ich fange um sieben Uhr an das ist richtig gut
Normalerweise um sieben auf der arbeit zu sein müsste ich mal richtig beschissen früh aufstehen und so kann ich ganz normal anfangen ich bin um sieben wach
Und da kann ich mich ganz normal an rechner setzen macht das ding an will mich per vpn ein und dann ist gut
Warum eigentlich kein artschchannel im discord wir haben doch wir haben doch ein linux channel oder
Das naheliegendste haben wir glaube ich gar nicht oder
Wir haben wir haben wir haben ein progress channel wo aber keiner checkt was sache ist
Warte mal ich muss da mal kurz reingucken
Unix port ja das trifft es aber nicht so ganz
Mordgis
Mordgis was haltet ihr denn davon wenn wir
Unter technik noch ein linux channel machen
Ich meine wir haben progress für programmierung zeug wir haben heim automatisierung und news
Ihr könnt euch das ja mal überlegen letztendlich letztendlich muss ihr den mist ja dann auch moderieren der da gepostet wird
Ja
Der eichler ist am start die wahrscheinlichkeit in new york von einem mensch gebissen zu wenigstens größer als die wahrscheinlichkeit in der fahrt
Wo hast du das her
Ich habe auch ich habe auch letztens gelesen dass es wahrscheinlicher ist in paris auf scheiße auszurutschen
und sich das knick zu brechen als
Ich weiß den vergleich nicht mehr als an irgendwas an
Als an irgendwas anderem zu sterben keine ahnung weiß ich was es war war ziemlich bescheuert der vergleich weil ich glaube da war einfach nur
ausgedacht
Habt ihr einen vpn klein oder always on vpn was ist denn ein always on vpn
Ach du meinst du was was automatisch mit gestartet wir beim os start und dass alles immer da drüber geht
Wir haben wir haben ein vpn klein
Der aber nur vom offiziellen laptop funktioniert also insofern macht es eigentlich keinen unterschied
Die nervigste zeit ist von 12 das stimmt also
Für mich wäre es nicht so wild ich bin ich brauche 20 minuten zu middagessen 12 bis 12 uhr 20
Dann ist vorbei
Aber ja das verstehe ich also gerade leute die in ruhe mal so 30 45 minuten mit nachessen wollen für die ist natürlich das eine doofe zeit
gerade wenn man dann so lange warten muss mit mit essen
Welchen desktop nutzt du in deiner archvm das kann ich dir zeigen die müssen wir immer booten und wieder ein update machen
Wenn es ein linux channel geben soll dann auch in windows channel aber da hat keiner schreibt das ist eine gute idee macht macht das so
mal kurz mal kurz update ge
Update gewähr eigentlich auch ein gutes emote
So entgegen
Update ge könnte so ein windows so ein windows kringel sein dass ich immer aktualisiert
Das gibt es doch bestimmt schon wenn update ge
emote
Ne gibt es nicht auf die idee ist noch keiner gekommen
update ge
Okay was gibt es hier zu zu updaten
Yay wird das so ein update ge
Yay wird geupdatet und pnpm wird geupdatet ja updatet ihr mal macht mal gebärm
Und pnpm wird geupdatet ja updatet ihr mal macht mal gebärm
Was nutzt du zum splinten im terminen also ich sag da gleich was zu ich muss den chat der reihe nach abarbeiten sonst sonst wird das nix
Also warum installiert der go moment was ist ach für yay ok also ich hab in meiner vm am start
Archlinux by the way selbstverständlich was sonst
Und als desktop habe ich i3
auf x also auf x x org x 11 wie auch immer man das nennen will
weil
Wayland in der vm nicht gescheit funktioniert
Ich ich verstehe nicht warum das ist aber wieder so ein typisches linux problem die schieben sich die schieben sich die die probleme
gegenseitig zu also
Die wehren leute sagt es muss vor immer fixen und vor immer sagt ist doch alles in ordnung x funktioniert doch auch
Zum beispiel zum beispiel funktioniert kein copy paste mit wayland
Es funktioniert noch nicht mal screen update seriously das wenn ich wehren starte mit sway oder so als winnow mensche
Ich habe null fps
Also der screen update sich nicht ich weiß gar nicht wie ich euch das begreiflich machen soll also das hört sich nicht so schlimm an
Aber es ist es ist schlimm weil der screen update sich nicht so also sobald ich wehren anmache habe ich nur einen schwarzen bildschirm
Weil das krein sich nicht automatisch mein bildschirm inhalt refreshed sich nicht
Der bildschirm bleibt für immer schwarz nur wenn ich terminal switch also nur wenn ich den hier mache
Wie quasi quasi ins ins terminal und wieder wieder auf wayland zurück dann
Refresh sich der screen einmal also ich habe quasi immer standbild bis ich terminal switch das ist halt nicht benutzbar
Ich meine ich kann ja ich kann ja schlecht manuell das screen refresh machen mit mit f1 f2 immer
Maus geht dementsprechend auch nicht
Als ich ja die maus nicht bewegt wenn sich das screen nicht refreshed logischerweise das kind das kann man das kann man mit einem
top secret parameter fixen aber dann bleibt immer noch
das problem dass man nicht copy pasten kann und copy pasten ist für mich halt
Essenziell wie soll ich das gescheitene vm benutzen ohne dass ich copy pasten kann zwischen host und dings
Übrigens ich habe zum ersten mal auf der neuen arbeit
unseren
schittrigs geht
Ja irgendwie jedes große jedes größere business enterprise ding hat irgend so ein zittrigs remote desktop ding rumstehen
Und ihr werdet sich vorstellen copy paste ist disabelt
Copy pastes disabled ich habe mir notizen gemacht lokal
und
Habe ich mir gedacht hey wenn der typ nachher im teams on kommt dann schickst du dem das
Da wollte ich ihm das schicken und ich konnte nicht copy pasten
Alles so highly secure dass man nicht arbeiten kann
So okay, wir haben geupdate ich reboot mal excellent
Also so jetzt muss ich das noch mal jetzt muss ich das noch mal beantworten
Also viel wo und er hat gesagt jetzt werde ich das noch mal erzählen also
Aber ich mache wirklich nur die kurzfassung weil es kann ich kann ich nicht alle viertel stunde neu erzählen
Also ich sage jetzt eine sache die ich gut finde eigentlich
neutral für die schlechte finde glaube ich die beste was ich wirklich gut finde fangen wir mit der guten sache zuerst an
ist dass der umgang untereinander und ich meine damit jetzt explizit nicht nur in meinem team
sondern auch team übergreifen ist viel netter und viel freundlicher als in der alten firma
Kann man nichts sagen also
Wie heißt das produkt owner und und projekt manager und
projekt leiter und
Entwickler und sowas das ist viel mehr man versucht was zusammen hinzukriegen
Als man fackt sich untereinander ab so wie es in der alten firma war also das ist viel besser die leute sind auch viel viel
Ja, so wie soll man sagen?
viel normaler im umgang mit nach
Viel normaler im umgang miteinander
Und nerven sich nicht permanent also das finde ich ist eine super sache so die atmosphäre und der umgang miteinander ist viel besser als aus dem
Gesichtspunkt gefällt mir wirklich gut
das neutrale ist
Ja, dass sie leiden auch unter viel zu vielen meetings ich habe es leider mein handy nicht hier sonst hätte ich euch mal vorlesen können
Am mittwoch hatte ich drei überlagerte meetings kein spaß
Drei das ist die zweite woche wo ich da bin wie kann man das schon drei überlagerte meetings ist doch eigentlich gar nicht möglich
Gut
Fairness haben wir davon wurden auch welche abgesagt wieder aber trotzdem mein das allein schon so was entstehen kann im kalender in der zweiten woche ist
doch nicht normal
So dass ich nie normal
Also dass das das ist das eine
Das ist neutral weil die alte firma leidet auch hat auch da wo ich vorher war hat auch sehr gelitten unter
viel zu vielen meetings
so
Und dann bleibt nur bleibt zum schluss noch das negative es ist super restriktiv alles ich verstehe es die haben auflagen die haben vorgaben und so
Aber teilweise ist es bis zur
Nichts ja nicht bedienbarkeit nicht benutzbarkeit
Bekompliziert ihr werdet ihr werdet lachen ich habe es bis heute nicht geschafft ich bin jetzt über eine woche da dass ich mich als senior
linux engineer auf einem linux per ssh einloggen kann
Ich habe heute mal wieder ein ticket aufgemacht wo es darum ging dass ich wenn ich mich einlogge keine security meldungen verursache
Weil meine logins gehen jetzt angeblich alle aber wenn ich mich einlogge
Erzeugt das automatisch eine security meldung weil ich nicht noch nicht weitlistet bin für login
Also log in geht prinzipiell schon ich bin noch nicht weitlistet so dass es kein security incident aufmacht das ganz ganz ganz extrem
wirklich total übertrieben
So und wie gesagt ich konnte mich bis jetzt noch nicht ein mal per ssh einloggen
Eher auf wegen der kiste das ist schon krass
Und
Dementsprechend ist halt auch so ein bisschen das problem
Dass du wirklich wegen jenem furz wohin rennen musst man kann ich einfach sagen ok kubernetes klassen war eine konfig
Gutes es gibt es eine team das macht dass das andere team macht dass das macht hier das ist so übergreifend
Aber eine gute sache ist zumindest in diesem projekt wo ich bin wo wir mit cloud kompanienes zeug machen die versuchen zumindest
So ein bisschen diese diese oldschool geschichte was er die firma bis vor kurzem noch gemacht hat das merkt man das merkt man dem laden auch an also
Die waren bis vor ganz kurzer zeit habe ich zumindest den eindruck sehr dinosaurier mäßig unterwegs ja das sieht man den dokumenten an das sieht man
den den
Formularen an den den workflow sind den 15 systemen die teilweise noch optimiert sind für microsoft internet explorer und solche dinge
Und auch sehr starre strukturen so hier da machen wir nichts da müsst ihr was machen aber hier berechtigung ist wieder ein anderer
Zertifikate ist wieder ein anderer cloud provisioning ist wieder ein anderer
Windows berechtigung ist wieder ein anderes team und so das ganze wir als ich habe hier einen ich kann es euch jetzt natürlich nicht im detail
Das ganze wir als ich habe hier einen ich kann es euch jetzt natürlich nicht im detail sagen es ist ja klar
Um die tech amends nicht mehr weiß ich weiß klein geschrieben was stopp muss großschreiben
Ich habe hier einen organik ram wie gesagt kann er jetzt nichts vorlesen kann er auch keinen namen sagen
Aber das organik ram und das ist nur it
Dieser it bereich in dem ich bin wenn ich das richtig sehe
Ja das ist nur dieser it bereich wo ich bin
Das organik ram ist so klein
Das hier quasi auf einer das ist das geht das braucht fast eine komplette a4 seite das organik ram also
Horizontal seitlich die seite und es ist so klein
Dass du es wirklich nur mit ganz viel anstrengung die namen lesen kannst
Also das ist wirklich ein großer großer laden
Und dementsprechend star war auch die war auch die die einteilung bisher
Ja und man merkt es halt sie versuchen es wirklich also ich habe den eindruck die wollen das echt also man merkt das in dem projekt dann
Da reden dann auch
admins mit entwicklern und
Mit dem hersteller von irgendeiner software und so das ist total
So was wie agil zu sein
In vielen fällen klappt es noch nicht so richtig weil eben so diese klasse zumindest mein eindruck als jemand neu ist weil so diese klassischen strukturen mit
berechtigung dürfen nur die machen zertifikate dürfen nur die machen
templates für provisioning bereitstellen dürfen nur die machen
Weil das einfach noch auch was vorgaben angeht viel zu viel zu tief verankert ist
Weil das einfach noch auch was vorgaben angeht viel zu viel zu tief verankert ist ja also ich könnte jetzt beispielsweise gar nicht hergehen und sagen
Weißt du was?
Kubernetes cluster aufbau mit terraform passt so nicht ich bastel mir mal was
Ich mache mir einfach neues git repo legt ein paar jammels rein apply das dann zum ausprobieren
Das wird wahrscheinlich allein schon an der stelle scheitern weil ich wenn ich in certain manager im kubernetes cluster installiere
Ich bin im certain manager nicht mit nichts machen kann weil
Zertifikatshändling wieder jemand ganz anderes macht und die wahrscheinlich vorgaben haben wie man mit ihrem service sprechen muss
Also mal da kurz was ausprobieren ist ist halt nicht das das nervt mich tatsächlich ein bisschen ich habe ja schon gewissen taten dran
Aktuell ja ich will schon was machen aber ich kann nichts machen
Ich kann einfach grad nichts machen und bei allem wo man wo sich mal ein bisschen was abzeichnet man könnte was machen
Bevor du dann wirklich was machen kannst musst du erst mal wieder mit 15 leuten reden
Also die hürde da überhaupt was zu machen ist so groß dass du eigentlich schon wieder gar keinen bock hast was zu machen also
Aber man also ich spüre zumindest den den zumindest in dem projekt den den den willen und den ansatz das in zukunft
Anders zu machen das ist ja was war ich bei meinem alten arbeitgeber gar nicht sagen konnte
Und ich deswegen gehe ich auch mal von aus die kriegen das gebacken innerhalb natürlich bei weitem nicht für alles da ist sein laden viel zu groß
Aber vielleicht für neue sachen bin ich zuversichtlich dass sie das über die nächsten paar jahre
durchaus hinkriegen dass das neue projekte gerade im cloud umfeld schon etwas weniger mit diesem
Alten ballast auskommen müssen
oder auskommen werden
Naja mal gucken mal gucken ob das dann so ist ja
Ja genau ich merke das auch
Ich habe heute habe ich mit meinem kollege im teams teams call gesessen
Hab gesagt hier hat er mir irgendwas gezeigt in ihrer container registry
Und genau die haben so einem die haben so einen meta
Ich weiß nicht wie das heißt gerade aus dem kopf die haben so eine meta registry da kann man container drinnen
registrieren da kann man
Helm charts reinpacken da kann man java binaries reinpacken da kann man
Docker Docker files reinpacken das ist so eine meta registry so so ein meta artefakt repo ding
Und da meinte sowas es ist nicht nexus
Da meinte sowas es ist nicht nexus es ist sowas wie nexus ich muss ich muss
Wobei artefaktory nexus ja sowas in der richtung ist das glaube ich zumindest
hatten wir es davon
Dass wir ab und zu vom hersteller
vorbereitete ja ich nenne es jetzt mal software das müsste ich euch ja mit dem detail erzählen das darf ich wahrscheinlich auch gar nicht
Vorbereitete sachen bekommen die in dieses repo reinkommen und mein kollege meinte also ihm schwebt ja vor
Er fände es wirklich cool wenn man das irgendwie automatisiert machen könnte
Also sprich die schicken uns das irgendwo hin wir packen das aus schieben das automatisch rein doch klar kann ich mache ich irgendwie in workflow oder
mache ich irgendwie meine meinte er dann zu mir
Ne wahrscheinlich wird das nix weil
Das das repo also dieses meta repo kann selbst zwar
Andere registries von anderen registrie pullen da haben wir aber wieder keine rechte das einzurichten
Wir haben aber auch keine reichte um der automatisch über die ab was rein zu pushen da müsste man wieder zum berechtigungsteam gehen um sich berechtigung zu beantragen
Da braucht man irgendwie wieder ein irgendwie eine stichhaltige Begründung zu dann muss das über irgendeine pipeline ausgerollt werden da sind da wieder ein anderes team
Also müsstest dass wir das automatisieren können das zu automatisieren an sich
Wahrscheinlich in sache von einer halben stunde oder sagen wir von 1 2 3 stunden
Mit dem was da dran hängt dass wir es überhaupt automatisieren können
Wahrscheinlich
2 3 monate und das ist halt krass
Der dieser ich meine das ernst ja also wie ich den den aufwand da bisher mitbekommen ist das wirklich so weil da
Da versandten dann auch viele sachen weil es um durch fünf teams durch muss muss ich das mal überlegen also wenn wir das automatisieren
Wir wirklich automatisieren wollen was hier eine sinnvolle sache ist
Was was 2 3 stunden dauert und man tatsächlich rumrennen muss dass es dann wochen und monate dauert bis es denn möglich ist
Da hat man nicht so wirklich bock was zu machen
Und ich meine das jetzt wirklich eins also die den eindruck hat hatte ich bisher dass so sachen aber wie gesagt nicht in dem projekt wo ich gerade bin
Aber also so bei in der klassischen welt dort dass einfache sachen teilweise monate dauern
2 3 monate für wirklich ganz einfache sachen weil so viele leute dran beteiligt sind dann muss dann muss im workflow irgendwie noch einer was
Genehmigen dann ist der nicht da da muss das irgendwie zum vertreter
Dann muss der irgendwie andere priorität zu machen
Und was auch immer also da ist also mit schnell ist da oftmals gar nix
So jetzt habe ich das auch beantwortet aber insgesamt eine sache finde ich richtig gut dass der umgang untereinander viel netter und viel freundlicher
Auch auch auch wie soll man sagen obwohl obwohl obwohl ich eigentlich am anfang gedacht habe
Dass sie da total steif sind ja das war so mein erster eindruck vom vorstellungsgespräch
Ist aber gar nicht so also wie ich im fort wie ich wie ich im vorstellungsgespräch war
Da bin ich da bin ich da reingekommen
Bin durch den gang gelaufen und da hatten die da war nur anzugträger erstmal
Und die einen haben irgendwie sowas wie caviar gefuttert
An an irgend so einem vielleicht hat da eine jubiläum oder sowas habe ich mir gerade alter wo bist du denn hier gelandet was denn hier los
Zum teufel ist die hier gelandet
Aber das ist gar nicht so dass das ist ein punkt den habe ich mir viel schlimmer vorgestellt
Ich dachte sie sind da halt alle super steif alle mit anzug und so ja ok es rennen viele mit anzug kommen und muss sagen
Es ist halt auch viel so so so so random smalltalk
ist ja auch alles ok aber der ich muss wirklich sagen der umgang dem anzug
Aber der ich muss wirklich sagen der umgang untereinander der ist zwar trotzdem sehr sachlich das ist nicht so dass die leute reinkommen
Sache alter was geht ja ne ne ist sehr sachlich aber der ist netter untereinander
Bei beim alten arbeitgeber wo ich war
Da war es umgedreht das war nicht so sehr sachlich
Dass du hattest dann wirklich einen hohen anteil an leute die die glaube ich den ganzen tag
Ihre aufgabe hatten andere erinnerungen
Und das habe ich bis jetzt dort
Ja gut gibt bestimmt einige leute die gerne andere nerven aber
Nicht in dieser konzentration habe ich das gesehen also der umgang insgesamt ist wirklich viel netter
Und auch auch jahrzehnt lösungsorientierter und
Angenehmer einfach nur kann man glaube ich sagen
Ja
Gut das habe ich ja schon beantwortet hier gerade
Guck mal das hast du aber einen keks ein monat
Und du kannst emotes verwenden guck mal wir haben ganz viele emotes hier die
Die sind ganz schön
Der browser ist gecrasht oder besser gesagt das tap ist gecrasht
Was extrem kacke sagen kann das sein dass ffz irgendwie probleme hat
Das ist halt ein mega sack weil ich war jetzt gerade sonst wo im chat
Das ist das ist mal richtig kacke man
Ja
Okay ich ich werde trotzdem die anderen sachen jetzt noch bei
Starbucks so ist es in der neuen bude hat er gefragt
Das hatten wir schon
Okay, er muss den chat neu auf machen keine ahnung warum der jetzt procken ist
Alter wenn ich
Was ist das denn wenn ich emotes anklicken geht der chat kaputt
Was haben sie da wieder getrieben
Wartet mal wir müssen mal kurz was gucken
prozess explorer
Messe feier gut password
Wir müssen mal gucken ob das auch viel auslastung verursacht hier sind wir
Liegt es am inkognito tab wahrscheinlich wobei warum sollte es weil weiß
So jetzt gucken wir mal ob das viel auslastung verursacht
Nein also es ist keine java script endlosschleife oder sowas
Ich weiß es nicht keine ahnung also also
Ich muss jetzt gerade mal kurz durch den durch den chat durchs krollen so also hier hier sind wir stehen geblieben
Okay
Okay also da ist ja gar nicht mehr viel drinne im chat jetzt eigentlich
Eigentlich was nutzt du terminal splitten ok also mittlerweile ist die vm wieder gebootet
Also was ich benutze um das terminal zu splitten das ist relativ einfach beantwortet es ist nicht team mux ich oder team max
Das habe ich nämlich gar nicht drauf
Das ist das terminal selber
Das ist westerm
Ich kann das nicht oft genug empfehlen meiner persönlichen ansicht nach das beste terminal beziehungsweise der beste terminal emulator muss man
Ja muss man ja korrekterweise sagen den es zur zeit gibt
Hat so viele geile sachen es ist cross-platform
linux mac windows
Es ist gpu rendert was ich persönlich jetzt
Ich verstehe den ehrlich gesagt den trend um gpu render terminals nicht weil
Terminals hatten jetzt noch nie das große problem dass die irgendwie gesondert grafisch intensiv
waren also
Known term war nicht gpu rendered und war auch immer schnell genug kein schimmer so wenn es ist es gpu rendered
Es hat eine super konfigurations datei in der man wirklich
Alles customisieren kann weil es eine vollständige programmiersprache quasi für die
Zeigst hier mal für die konfigurations datei hat also sie ist ich kann hier tatsächlich dass nur
Interpreter den sie da drinne haben ich kann tatsächlich hier eigene funktionen
Programmieren und das auf tasten beinden und schleifen machen beste konfiguration zum beispiel was das hier macht dass man mal sieht als es auch wirklich sinnvoll ist
Da was ich auf meiner rechten maus taste habe auf meiner rechten maus taste habe ich folgendes wenn ich was an klicke
doppelt jetzt doppelt links angeklickt wenn ich was doppelt links an klicke dann verhält sich meine rechte maus taste anders als wenn
Ich nichts angeklickt habe und zwar folgendermaßen wenn ich eine selection habe dann
performt die rechte maus taste copy to clipboard
Und klirt die selection wieder jetzt ich klick das hier an rechte maus taste copy to clipboard clipboard hier streak da ist es drinne
Wenn ich nichts
Selectet habe dann kann ich euch auch mal zeigen ich zeige ich jetzt mal hier so klick klick rechte maus taste
Selection in clipboard ist selection geklärt und wenn ich jetzt wieder rechts klicke
Dann ist rechte maus taste paste also meine rechte maus taste toggle zwischen copy und paste
Sie ist copy solange ich was selectet habe und sie ist paste wenn ich nicht selectet habe
Finde ich sehr praktisch ich kann das nämlich einfach machen hier klick klick und jetzt mache ich rechts rechts und
Es ist eingefügt man kann übrigens auch einfach mittlere maus das geht genauso aber finde ich ist eine coole sache und man sieht
Wie nice man sich das terminal konfigurieren kann ja dann haben sie noch viele andere sachen dabei die haben hier
splitting splitting support
Sie haben mittlerweile glaube ich auch die möglichkeit dass es im hintergrund läuft dann kannst du zum beispiel noch
Es hat sogar image support und nicht einfach nur image support
Du kannst auch sogar gifs im terminal abspielen
Also ist das ist richtig hier im terminal drin das ist nix irgendwie
Overlates oder sowas das render das wirklich ins terminal das verwendet das item zwei image protokoll
Das ist das ist ein mech terminal und sie haben das anscheinend mal erfunden irgendwann
Und auch viel mehr du musst die seite mal angucken aber west arm ist wirklich das beste was ich kenne
Ich finde man braucht sowas gar nicht mehr wenn man das hat
Ja du hast du ziemlich alle t-marks funktionen die man die man kennt du kannst
horizontal split ganz wertig
Horizontal split ganz vertikal splitting du kannst einzelne ja zeige ich mal
Du kannst einzelne sachen groß machen klein machen also zoomen
Zoomen
Du kannst die sachen switchen mit der mit der maustaste du kannst die sachen switchen mit
So mit dem mit dem mit der tastatur kannst du die switch mit der maustaste kannst du ganz unabhängig von anders krollen
Ah du kannst hier da rein pasten und sowas
Also wie gesagt bestes terminal
Eskalieren kannst du auch habe ich aber gerade gar nicht gebunden du kannst dann die default die default key bindings sind ein bisschen blöd
Du kannst die schrift größer und kleiner machen ja und wieder zurück auf null stellen also standard mäßig ist plus
control plus minus schrift groß und klein
Und control gleich als zeichen wieder zurücksetzen oder null zur zurücksetzen auf standard habe ich aber nicht gebunden weil ich mach
Eigentlich so gut wie nie die schrift anders ich brauche es höchstens manchmal wenn ich was copy pasten will das passt nicht alles rein
Loll mal dankeschön für den sub
Du nutzt nicht paru das ist blazingly fast das ist richtig ich benutze tatsächlich nicht paru
Es ist in dem fall hier die frage will ich ein tool in go will ich ein tool in rust und ich sag's dir ganz ehrlich wie
Sie ist mir ist es egal in welcher programmier sprache das tool programmiert ist es könnte sogar ein c++ sein
Das das muss gut funktionieren und das ist ein gutes package managen beziehungsweise user repo managen tool
Beziehungsweise user repo management tool
Insofern sehe ich kein ich vorher habe ich das hier verwendet
Vorher habe ich das verwendet das war ein pearl programmiert können wir folgen
Seriously also ich habe wirklich jahrelang in den pearl programm verwendet für user repo management wird es überhaupt noch
wird es überhaupt noch weiterentwickelt
Sporadisch wahrscheinlich es hat noch nicht mal es hat noch nicht mal eine readme
Um massig viele offene
Ja aber das stimmt ich verwende ich verwende das nicht
Filtet dankeschön für den sub any primers die primers haben gerade schon reingesubbt
Wenn es natürlich noch mehr primers gibt könnt ihr weiter rein subben vielleicht kann ich noch mehr
Reingesubbt
Wenn es natürlich noch mehr primers gibt könnt ihr weiter rein subben vielleicht kriegen wir den scam train heute irgendwann noch mal auf die reihe
Also das ist der grund warum ich warum ich weiter hier und ich paro benutze weil wozu es macht alles was ich will ist es schnell genug
Und mir ist mir egal in was die tools programmiert sind solange ich an den nicht selbst schrauben will und sie funktionieren ist alles wunderbar
Reizel ich glaube so wolltest du ausgesprochen werden
Poggers 29 monate subscription dazu kann ich sagen
Hast du eine idee warum bei vm wer copy paste nicht funktioniert es ist hostess winners gäste sein artig ja
battleship das kann ich dir sagen
Du musst mir aber gleich in chat schreiben ob es funktioniert hat wenn du es ausprobiert
Ich kann dir sagen woran das vor woran das liegt du musst das hier installieren
Gtk mm 3 wohlgemerkt nicht. Gtk mm nicht. Gtk mm 4 nein
Gtk mm 3 und du musst sicherstellen dass
System ctl status vm tools d
Dass das läuft die zwei sachen wenn das wenn das läuft wenn das siehst du ja auch wenn du hier
Reza ist und da passt die auflösung an dass es funktioniert die zwei sachen und dann geht copy paste
Probierst mal aus und sag mir gleich mal bescheid aus funktioniert das wird höchstwahrscheinlich sein gut wenn es weyland ist hast du eh keine
Chance also es sei denn du verwendest also wenn du weyland verwendest in der vm kannst du kannst du knicken geht nicht
Kleine frage wo und geht's geht's
Kleine zusammenhanglose frage wo läuft haumas ist bei den einer vm ja siehste chat
Only high iq im chat ist das möglich dass wir hier so live live support machen
Ohne euch wäre das alles nicht möglich gewesen wenn mein brain viel zu klein
Richtig richtig pockt der chat wieder das war das falsche imaut aber egal
Ja also kleine zusammenhanglose frage wohl läuft haumas ist das bei den einer vm ja das läuft in meiner vm
Auf meinem hp
Microserver gen bohr fragt mir nicht
Was ist der letzte microserver den es aktuell so gibt
Gen 10 plus ja kann das
Ja dieses teil auf diesem ding ja so ein teil genau
Alter so ein teil habe ich bei mir hinten im rack stehen ja es steht im rack auch wenn es nicht rack
Bauweise ist aber man ist doch egal es gibt auch platz den rein zu stellen
Und wer denkt ich hätte den riesen in riesen rack nee ganz so ganz so groß ist es auch
Nicht ich habe den mini ich habe den mini regg
Guck da sieht man's
Aber sind schlecht bisschen kacke winkel aber man sieht's also ja werkzeug werkzeug warmen kisten
Paar verteiler dosen fürs haus 3d drucker
Und wer denkt ich hätte den riesen in riesen rack nee ganz so ganz so groß ist es auch nicht
3d drucker und hier ganz beste
Werra toolcheck plus so und dann
Ja hier unten sieht man das sieht man das die die unify access points sind schon längst wieder weg
Hier habe ich alle rausgeschmissen
Die sind gebannt
unify access points
Ich glaube ich gehe hier irgendwann auch noch mal durch das rack durch sieht man hier was
Nö ich drücke einfach nur sinnlos hier oben auf dem tablet ok ah nee doch hier gehe ich mal kurz durchs rack durch alles klar
Ja also das da oben kriegen wir vielleicht irgendwie ein bild wo es ein bisschen schärfer ist so man ist immerhin 4k
Ah
Halbweg switch halbweg schärfer das ist ein edge switch 16 xs oder so
Das ist ein 10 gigabit switch von unify von ubiquity aber kein unify switch ein edge switch
Der hat 12 glasfaser ports beziehungsweise stimmt ja gar nicht sehen kann keine glasfaser ports der hat 12
Sfp plus ports und ihr seht zum größten teil verwende ich die gar nicht mit modulen und glas
Sondern bei verwende ich hier auf dem bild überhaupt ein mit modul und glasfaserkabel nö gar nicht ich habe
zweimal direct attach kopforkabel drinne 10 gigabit
und ich habe
Einen glaube ich ist das einen weiteren
45 10 gigabit da habe ich mal so ein modul gekauft billig und das andere sind tatsächlich noch mal 2 gigabit module und das hier sind
Er 45 10 10 g auch dort so ein keystone panel
So ein komisches bürschending zum zum kabel durch machen steckerleiste
Und unten drunter ist ja max kommen wir spulen ein bisschen vor
Ja die alte kiste gibt es nicht mehr die gibt es nicht mehr
Hier unten drunter habe ich so eine schublade die kann man rausziehen das steht eine fritzbox drauf das
das wurde von kabel modem mein mikrotik router
Und unten drunter hier steht jetzt hier steht jetzt der hp microserver hier zu dem zeitpunkt standen auch diese billig 2hkiste
Drinnen die habe ich aber rausgeschmissen
Jetzt habe ich dem microserver am start genau hier sieht man den hex poe richtig guter router kostet nicht viel
super krass also wirklich extrem viele features
Ich weiß netzwerk netzwerk
Profis werden mich jetzt hauen wenn ich sage das ist ein profi gerät weil ich sage nein in meinen rechenzentrum kommt auf gar keinen fall mikrotik
Da kann ich nur entgegnen ja
Wenn ihr genug geld habt euch nur cisco und sonstige dinger kaufen zu können ist gut macht das alles ja wunderbar
Aber von features her und preisleistung gibt es
Einer an sich nach fast nichts besseres in diesem bereich als mikrotik
So
Geschwätzt der kann übrigens auch poe der kann sogar noch poe das teil
Fritz box
Ja sonst ist glaube ich nichts spannendes material so jetzt bei mir ein bisschen ein bisschen werkzeugwerkzeugwerkzeug flexier
Das das wäre ein joker set
So und irgendwie eine rgb eine sinnlose rgb lampe die da drinne steht ja
Super das hat die welt gebraucht leute die rgb rgb lampe im surferraum
Dadurch ist alles noch mehr blazing li fast und es muss nicht written in rust sein das funktioniert auch so
Gut wunderbar
Also so jetzt haben wir das beantwortet und ja darauf läuft mein home assistant in einer vollem
M ist auch viel einfacher also ich könnte ich könnte mich vielleicht auch dazu durchregen den home assistant auf
Irgendwann singen muss ja kein raspberry pi auf in einem singelbord computer laufen zu lassen mit ssd wäre auch eine möglichkeit
Oder auf in dem nuke oder in so einem kleinen mini pc das kann man auch machen kann man aber nämlich habe sie in der vm laufen
Was ist deine meinung zu IT consultancy
Hat grüß dich 187 und gefragt fange bald nach meinem master also ich kann euch die frage nicht mehr zeigen
Ich hab den chat reloaded fange bald nach dem master an als informatinga in frankfurter main und hab bisschen schiss vor vor den fachfremden kollegen
Und als sterben stand ich schon mal mitións lange underground trinken hab 정es schon einechnisch
Und hab bisschen schiss vor vor den fachfremden kollegin
Keine ahnung ich habe nie in so einer konsultenbude gearbeitet ich persönlich erkennt mich ich habe eh nicht die allerhöchste meinung von von den
meisten konsulten weil
das wort konsulten
bedeutet ja eigentlich
Dass man den konsultiert wenn man selber nicht mehr weiter weiß
Und es gab in der gesamten zeit wo ich jetzt hier professionell in der IT tätig bin nur sehr wenige momente
Wo ich keine ahnung hatte aber ein konsultant es wusste
Beziehungsweise einen der konsultants die dafür bezahlt wurden auch wirklich sein geld wert war das kam tatsächlich relativ selten vor also ich bin der meinung vieles davon ist einfach nur
Leute die gut schwätzen können und technisch nicht nicht so drauf haben können sich gut verkaufen
Ansonsten kann ich dir da wirklich nicht viel viel zu sagen
Fachfremde leute sind kein problem es sei denn sie finden sich empfinden sich selbst als irgendwie als was
Was überlegen ist gibt ja manche leute sind ganz komisch drauf so nach dem motto die haben nicht verstanden dass es jetzt nicht rum geht
Dagegenander zu arbeiten sondern die können was gut und du kannst was gut
Also geben wir mal von ganz klassischen fall aus du bist so turnst du admin klein support du rennst durchs unternehmen
tauscht drucker patronen baus bildschirme auf
Fix vielleicht in einer anderen access point hilfst den aber so das was ich wirklich sehr ungern noch machen würde aber immer von aus
So da gibt es ja leute die da ganz gerne immer so doofe sprüche drüber machen ja die IT will ich dass man arbeitet und
Ja könnt ihr denn über also die spielen sich dann immer auf das ist das finde ich dann immer ein bisschen bisschen kacke
Weil die wahrscheinlich in ihrem eigentlichen job auch extrem beschissen sind
Das gerade der gag da dran dass die wahrscheinlich auch richtig kacke sind
Und sie das andere aber gar nicht richtig einschätzen können
Ja aber ansonsten das ist zunehmend weniger muss man ehrlich sagen also
Auch auch zumindest ist mein eindruck gut beim neuen arbeitgeber weiß ich ja beim alten jetzt ist die letzten jahre über auch besser
geworden weil die management etage auch
Beziehungsweise auch falle das mittlere management da war das sehr verbreitet
Jünger geworden ist und nicht mehr und nicht mehr so boomer mäßig ja
Weil man muss eine sache sich mal überlegen das muss jetzt mal in puncto management loswerden
Gute manager sind was sinnvolles das sagen IT lehr auch nicht gerne das ist ein bisschen so so wie
auf der einen seite macht man immer witzchen drüber
über irgendwelche IT sachen und auf der anderen seite IT leute sagen immer mannager brauchst du nicht könnte man ohne machen stimmt beides nicht
gute manager
sind wirklich sinnvoll sie sind vor allem dafür sinnvoll
dir den rücken freizuhalten dass du in ruhe was machen kannst
Beziehungsweise die rahmen bedingungen dafür zu schaffen dass du
Sicher was machen kannst ohne dass du dir dass du angst haben muss dass sie dass sie den abmahnung kassiert oder ohne dass der angst haben
Muss es beschwert sich jetzt irgendeine also gute manager oder besser gesagt auch gute mannager sein gute
Führungskräfte die dafür sorgen dass man eben weiß
Wo die eigenen aufgaben anfangen und wo sie aufhören
und der einem
Der einen auch unterstützt wenn man beispielsweise
Irgendwas braucht und die andere seite sagt das können wir nicht machen das ist wirklich gut also das sollte man
sich mal gedanken drüber machen auch als IT lehr das gute manager und gute führungskräfte dass das auch was wichtiges ist
Leider gibt es da nicht so viele von
Aber ich habe den eindruck dass das die letzten jahre über besser geworden ist
Um so mehr jüngere in diesem in diesem job angekommen sind früher war das eher so was in der richtung
Ich möchte führungskraft werden nicht weil ich mich gut eignen als manager oder als führungskraft sondern weil ich mir davon erhoffe mehr geld zu bekommen
Dass das das war das war so das ding früher so nach dem motto die einzige karriereleiter die einzige aufstiegsmöglichkeiten
Dies gegeben hat war ja macht mal irgendwie ein bisschen
Personalverantwortung projektmanagement oder sonst was das ist glücklicherweise in vielen unternehmen mittlerweile nicht mehr so die sind mittlerweile schlau genug gewesen
Zu sagen hey ein guter IT la
Muss kein guter manager sein und dementsprechend muss auch
Ja gut umgedreht ist muss ich nicht sagen umgedreht ist das glaube ich jedem klar
Ein guter manager sein muss aber
Ich glaube dass das die letzten jahre über
Eine entwicklung gab nämlich dahin dass man nicht mehr sagt hey
So personalverantwortung projektmanagement soll ich sagen sie die einzigen aufstiegsmöglichkeiten sondern dass man jetzt versucht
Dass es sowohl die möglichkeiten gibt für leute die im management was machen wollen sich weiter zu entwickeln aber auch für leute
Die in der IT bleiben wollen sich weiter zu entwickeln weil es kann ja eigentlich nicht im sinne der firma sein oder im sinne des unternehmens sein
dass wenn du einem wenn du ein gutes
Wenn du wenn du guter techniker bist dass du dann ein schlechter manager wirst und dazu gezwungen
Wirst weil es quasi die einzige aufstiegsmöglichkeit gibt das kann ja weder in deinem interesse sein noch im interesse des unternehmens sein noch in dem interesse
vielleicht das firm so das team so das projekts was du dann später leitest das kann es eigentlich nicht sein
war aber lange zeit so
war aber lange zeit so und das hat sich nur die letzten
Sieben acht jahre hat es angefangen oder zehn jahre vielleicht wenn es hochkommt hat sich das so langsam aber sicher immer immer weiter
verbessert in dem sie nämlich jetzt sagen hey es gibt weiterhin die möglichkeit sich in die
Führungs
Führungskraft
Karriereweg einzuschlagen oder projekt management karriereweg einzuschlagen wenn man das will
Oder aber auch es gibt die möglichkeit für IT leute sowas zu werden erst mal
junior normal senior
Experte architekt und was ist da nicht alles noch für steigerungen und unterschiedliche positionen gibt und das ist sinnvoll
Die leute können sich nämlich weiterentwickeln und dementsprechend unterm strich natürlich auch mehr geld verdienen aber in was was sie gut können
Und nicht dass du irgendwann sagen muss ok ich muss jetzt management scheiß machen obwohl ich da kein bock drauf habe als IT
Also das ist die letzten jahre über wirklich nicht schlecht geworden ja also
noch mal zu die sache mit mit fahrfremden kollegen also
Ich glaube nicht dass man ein bisschen schützt dass man schiss vor den leuten haben muss also dieses dieses von oben herab der IT behandeln ist
Eigentlich mittlerweile nahezu ausgestorben was man auch aktuell sieht die können sich ja auch gar nicht überleisten die finden ja keine
Du findest irgend so ein typ
Der ein bisschen office klicken kann und da irgendwelche büroarbeiten erledigen kann also die die typischen verdächtigen
Die blödes zeugs labern wenn IT technisch was nicht funktioniert da findest du tausend
tausend leute stehen nach schlange um den job zu machen
für deinen job
IT technisch
ist die schlange nicht
Tausend leute lang sondern die ist die die ist minus 300 leute
Da ist quasi kommt zwar gar in lange zeit erst mal gar nix
Die können sich das heute auch gar nicht mehr leisten ja so so blöd so blöd zu kommen
Und das haben glaube ich auch viele unternehmen mittlerweile gecheckt also da würde ich da würde ich mir nicht so viel würde ich mir nicht mehr so
Viel gedanken darüber machen also sei fast ausgestorben
Dass die dass sich da irgendwelche leute aufspielen so als sie werden was besseres
Okay
Okay also noch eine frage von keksdose keksdose fragt
ich muss für meine
Vm die virtualisierung für meine cpu aktivieren ist das aber nicht
ungesund für meine teile wenn ich vm mode im bios aktiviere nein
Das ist eine cpu funktion die deine cpu e hat und die kannst du im bios aktualisieren
Aktivieren und das ändert sich einfach gar nichts außer dass du ordentlich virtualisieren kannst
Also das kannst du anschauen du kannst übrigens bei der gelegenheit wenn du gerade bios bist schalten virtualisierung an schalten vtd an
Schalte vt. Boah wie heißt das neue zeug keine ahnung
iomu an die ganze virtualisierung zeug schalt an
an das trinken erinnern dankeschön mach ich
Vt schalt das alles an das schadet nichts
Ja
Serious magst du es lachen es gibt ja theoretische möglichkeiten sich per ssh zu tunneln
Aber ich will ich gleich in den security incident auslösen in der zweiten wahl wo ich da bin
weil es jemand merkt
Also dort wo ich dir auch beim provider dort wo ich die ausbildung gemacht habe da hat er auch der azubi am ersten tag sudo
Ruder rechte das ist wirklich das krasse gegenteil zu dem wo ich jetzt bin
Drachenflieger hat eine random frage und zwar also chat random frage von drachenflieger
Könnt ihr in den chat schreiben ob das bei euch auch so ist er sagt jo mal eine random frage kriegt ihr auch gerade
whispers von irgendwelchen usern die ein zu only fans baiten
Nee ich krieg keine wissbar weil ich wissbar ausgeschaltet habe ich kann nur
angewispert werden in twitch wenn ich vorher geschrieben habe
Only fans von max ich habe kein only fern ich habe nur fans lie die kassieren nicht so viel die kassieren nicht so viel provisionen
Fans liebeste
xvx fragt aber macht das spaß dann
Zu arbeiten wenn man nichts machen kann ja mal gucken wie sich das entwickelt ja
Aktuell ist es schon ein bisschen nervig
Er schreibt er ist lieber die fraktion ich habe frei war es läuft wie am teil naja gut also ganz im ernst das ist jetzt die zweite woche
Es kann durchaus sein dass es da mittel und wege gibt sich legal zu tunneln dass man doch gescheit arbeiten kann
Ich spüre ja den willen dass man sich da gut umsetzen kann
Ich spüre ja den willen von dem unternehmen eindeutig sich ein bisschen in zukunft
Agiler auszurichten das merkt man auch an allen ecken und enden bei dem projekt dass man es versucht das geht mit vielen alten strukturen noch nicht
Ich kann es einfach sagen ich bin erst seit zwei wochen da also ich weiß gar nicht wie es vorher war
Ich kenne es jetzt auch nur in diesem projekt und da geben sie sich wirklich mühe
Und ansonsten jetzt mal ganz nüchtern betreffend
Und ansonsten jetzt mal ganz nüchtern betrachtet
Natürlich ist es doof und es frustriert auch ein bisschen wenn man zu 15 sachen
Leuten rennen muss um was einfaches zu machen oder wenn eine zwei bis drei stunden
automatisierungsaufgabe am ende dann in zwei bis drei monaten ausartet weil du zu gott und der welt rennen musst und
Sachen aber jetzt mal ganz ganz nüchtern ganz nüchtern betrachtet
Die bezahlen mir so viel kohle
Und wenn die nicht wollen dass ich was arbeite
Weil ich mich nirgendswo einloggen kann oder keine berechtigung habe irgendwas zu machen oder
15 stunden statt
Eine brauche um irgendwie kubaniertes technisch was zu testen oder ich den halben tag nur am mieten bin keine ahnung sollen sie machen
Dann mache ich halt nichts gescheites ja aber kassiert trotzdem fettkohle also insofern
Meinen wegen es ist zwar ein bisschen doof ja aber wie gesagt ich sehe auf der einen seite dass ich das durchaus potential hat
Zu verbessern sowohl kurzfristig weil man vielleicht doch sich irgendwie legal
tunneln kann so dass man gescheit arbeiten kann
Als auch mittelfristig weil das unternehmen sich verbessern will auf der anderen seite die bezahlen mir genug
War ich das auch so
letztendlich ist unterm strich das wofür wir arbeiten gehen
Klar gehen wir auch gehen wir auch ein bisschen arbeiten dafür
Weil wir technisch was gescheites auf die reihe kriegen wollen und das ist natürlich gut
Oder motivierend wenn man technisch auch was gescheites auf die reihe kriegt das keine frage
Aber unterm strich gehen wir doch zum größten teil aber in der führer als kohle gibt
Und kohle gibt es genug also insofern
So ich habe den chat gleich gleich durch
Man muss so wie der pressend sein da ich muss zum größten teil gar nicht pressend sein
Ich bin aktuell einmal die woche vor ort in frankfurt und in zukunft wahrscheinlich alle 14 tage
Kekso sehr dankeschön für den primes ab
Ja
Ich habe westerm gesagt ja nicht westterm westterm also wie ez term
Hast du track und drop für datel mit westerm hinbekommen habe ich noch gar nicht ausprobiert
Loll mann filth danke für den sub ich glaube jetzt bin ich langsam ran gescrollt
Okay
Hetzten hat neue armbase cloud server angekündigt nee, aber wir könnten mal wieder einen sponsoring machen schon eine ganze weile her
Welch dabei weiß bloß nicht was ich gescheit mit armen hardware zeigen soll habt ihr eine gute idee für armen hardware
Ist das ein startech rack was ich hab nein
Wie ist der router der router hieß ich kann es jetzt sagen hex poe mikro tic hex poe nicht leid nicht leid normal
hex poe
Kostet jetzt anscheinend irgendwie
Der das ding hat mal 60 euro gekostet vorne vor der wahl okay zu 94
Ist ganz schön teuer geworden die letzten jahre über ja dieses teil ist das
Das hier übrigens nicht jebaiten lassen nicht jebaiten lassen
Das hier ist
Sfp nicht sfp plus
Aber insgesamt das ding 1 2 3 4 5 es steht sogar da 5 6 ports
Und das da internet steht dürfte euch auch nicht jebaiten lassen das ist die default konfig ist so eingestellt dass das intern ist
Das ding das ding hat auch nicht mal eine richtige default konfig ihr könnt in irgendeinem quick assistent totaler blödsinn
Ihr könnt alle ports verwenden wie ihr wollt also die beschriftung ist total bescheuert ihr könnt auch alles intern verwenden alles
Ihr könnt auch jedes jedes ein eigenes
Netz anschließen vollkommen egal also es hat nichts damit zu tun auch wenn es da drauf steht
Doch
Bild x mit arm 64 target
Weiß ich keksdose schreibs nochmal ich habe es glaube ich noch nicht gesehen ich bin doch nicht so weit
Und
Moin patrick ist ja auch da sehe ich ja jetzt erst
Kannst du den chat ich glaube jetzt habe ich es doch hier oder du bist auch hier hier sind wir ok alles klar so ich hab den chat ich habe den check
Kannst du den chat kannst du chat mal fragen ob jemand eine lösung für mein db probleme die sind feifett ja das ist richtig
Wir wissen ja alle die entwicklung von chat gpt und solchen sachen hätte man sich komplett sparen können
Hätten die gewusst dass es den wubblers chat gibt auf twitch
Also mein chat ist eindeutig größer chat gpt was mir heute auch schon wieder eindrucksvoll gesehen hat
Also wenn ich das richtig im kopf habe hat der patrick folgendes problem
Er hat eine anwendung mit die eine datenbank braucht die sich allerdings synchronisieren soll allerdings
auch offline fähig sein soll also sprich
Er will eine datenbank
Wenn die leute dass die leute mit der software arbeiten können wenn sie offline sind und wenn sie online sind soll sich die datenbank quasi automatisch
sünden mit irgendwie nah
Master
Geschichte
Ich kann das
Ob ich es richtig verstanden habe also er will quasi eine mischung haben aus so was wie cassandra db so quasi
verteilt auf der welt
Und eskült für lokal und das in einer datenbank irgendwie sowas in der richtung
Kautsch db ich habe keine ahnung
Ich frage euch jetzt einfach er muss es er muss es selbst noch mal schreiben so genau habe ich es nicht gecheckt
Ich trinken habe ich gerade gemacht
Was nutzt ihr für vpn für die arbeit
Ich weiß es nicht wie der anbieter heißt ehrlich gesagt
Würde ich euch wahrscheinlich auch nicht erzählen
Ich würde ich euch wahrscheinlich auch nicht erzählen
Ich weiß es nicht wie der anbieter heißt ehrlich gesagt würde ich euch wahrscheinlich auch nicht erzählen
Wofür das tunnel näher dass ich zum beispiel ein gescheites terminal habe und ich mobile x-term verwenden muss
Gegen welche access point hast du die unify access point getauscht ok das haben wir schon tatsächlich den eigenen stream zugemacht
Aber ich werde es trotzdem noch mal kurz zeigen ich habe mir auf ebay access points gekauft und zwar
rugos r710
Und guck mal gibt gerade sogar relativ günstig ein
Es gibt wieder welche leute das letzte mal waren die ultra ultra teuer also nur mal so dass ihr wisst in welchen regionen diese access point normalerweise
Gehackt habe na das ist ein bisschen zu übertrieben aber ja die dinger also normalerweise kosten diese access point neu
So zwischen 1200 und 1500 euro das sind quasi gold access points
Diamant access points
Wenn man sich überlegt die meisten leute denken sie haben schon richtig krasses netzwerkequipment wenn sie sich für 150 euro
unify access point gekauft haben
Also die dinger sind noch mal komplett anderes level was der preis angeht
Aber die habe ich natürlich auch nicht gekauft für den preis sondern ich habe bei ebay geguckt und habe quasi eine
Eigentlich doch eine generation älter eine generation älter gekauft
Es sind in wirklich keinen eigentlich eineinhalb generation die haben wir so ein zwischen release
Und so welche habe ich mir gekauft ich habe gewartet bis es die günstig gab
Und ich habe mir zwei stück also insgesamt habe ich sogar drei stück ich habe mir 510 r6 10 r7 10
Im einsatz habe ich allerdings nur den r510 den r710
Und den r610 habe ich um hier mal im stream sachen zu testen und sowas ich habe meines gekauft für irgendwie um die 150 euro bis
250 euro
bisschen bisschen geschwenkt
Müsst ihr mal gucken oftmals gibt es bei ebay klein anzeigen auch leute die wollen welche abgeben
Leider kann ich über klein anzeigen nicht benutzen weil die mich gebannt haben die haben mich gebannt obwohl ich nie ein account dort hatte
Ich weiß nicht wie sie genauso das gemacht haben aber sie haben es geschafft
So das sind die access points die ich habe der hauptgrund warum ich diese also was heißt der hauptgrund ist
Der ausschlaggebende punkt glaube ich muss man aus muss man so nennen der ausschlaggebende punkt warum ich die access points habe
beziehungsweise warum ich die unify access points rausgeschmissen habe ist weil die unify access points ein ganz
für mich
wichtiges feature nicht haben
Was ich aber haben möchte und so gut wie jeder größere hersteller
in irgendeiner art und weise mittlerweile sowas kann nur
unify ubiquity nicht und zwar was ich meine ist
bei ruckus, ruckus wie auch immer nennt sich das dynamic dpsk also dpsk dynamic
pre-shared key
klingt kompliziert
Im prinzip ist es ganz einfach erklärt
Normalerweise müsst ihr ein passwort eingeben wenn ihr euch mit eurem wlan verbindet und dieses wlan passwort
Habt ihr vielleicht auch schon festgestellt oder ich weiß nicht wie ihr das macht könnt ihr meinen chat schreiben
Dieses wlan passwort ist für alle geräte die sich in diesem wlan anmelden gleich oder
Ist doch ist doch bei euch so oder chat es sei denn es sei denn ihr verwendet wpa enterprise mit einem radioserver
Dahinter das ist ein bisschen anders aber dann
Muss das endgerät das unterstützen
Also ihr habt wahrscheinlich so dass jedes gerät was ins wlan rein muss exakt das gleiche wlan passwort braucht
ein anderes wort für wlan passwort oder passwort ist
pre-shared key
Ist das gleiche damit gemeint
Und was die dinger können und was so gut wie jede andere hersteller mittlerweile auch kann
in irgendeiner art und weise zumindest mal ein bisschen besser mal ein bisschen schlechter implementiert
Aber was jeder hersteller außer ubiquiti kann
Ist dpsk
Die wollen einfach nicht die haben die haben einfach die haben einfach kein bock
Das stimmt das stimmt überhaupt nicht was der typ schreibt das stimmt was ist das für ein bullshit das stimmt überhaupt nicht
Jeder hersteller hat mittlerweile so was wie dpsk ja
Ruckus nennt es dpsk die andere nennen es mpsk oder
Ppsk aber es ist alles das gleiche oder ähnlich das ist totaler bullshit was das was ist das wieder für ein schwätzer hier auf reddit alter
Der einzige grund ist unify hat kein bock ist zu faul kriegt sich gebacken was auch immer
Sie sind sind der einzige etwas höher preisige wlan geräte hersteller die das nicht können
Sogar mikrotik kann es bei ihren 60 euro access points
TP-link oma da kann es auch
Cisco kann es logischerweise
Aruba kann es auch was gibt es da noch alles
Ich kenne mich bei wlan geräten nicht so aus was haben wir da sonst noch also was gibt es da sonst noch so chat
high iq chat messages brauchen wir jetzt
Sache helfen was gibt es noch für große wlan hersteller
netgear ob es netgear kann keine ahnung
Keine netgear wahrscheinlich nicht
Was gibt es was gibt es denn sonst noch
Meraki gibt es wobei ich glaube meraki ist jetzt auch sysco
Na gut die fritzbox kann das nicht die fritzbox kann ich mal wlan's
Aber die fritzbox ist trotzdem ein gutes gerät allerdings kein guter guter aber gut ist wohl die funktionsgerät
Ja ruckus kann glaube ich auch nur 4096 wenn man es mit unleashed verwendet
Ja und deswegen habe ich mir die gekauft weil das ein feature ist was für mich sehr praktisch ist ich habe sehr viele kleine
IOT geräte die ich auch mal in müll schmeißen will und damit open vrt kann es mittlerweile auch open vrt kanns mittlerweile auch
Und wenn ich wenn ich irgendein microcontroller in müll schmeißt sind ja noch meine wlan extra sind auch noch meine wlan
Zugangsdaten drauf ich stelle euch vor das ding ist kaputt gegangen ich kann es nicht mehr überflaschen sind da meine wlan zugangsdaten drauf
das will ich ja nicht
Also dpsk extra password pro gerät gerät wegschmeißen dpsk löschen fertig deswegen habe ich die ersetzt
Ja die kosten ein bisschen mehr
Also die kosten die gebrauchten kosten quasi schon so 50 bis 100 euro mehr als den unify
access point
Aber sie haben einfach die besseren features und ich finde sie auch
verarbeitungstechnisch und auch
vom vom ja vom wlan an sich
besser im vergleich zu den unify access points wir hatten zum beispiel schon ganz lange
Das was jetzt neu ist in wifi 6 in wifi 6 gibt es ja diese diese beam forming geschichten so dass sie quasi die
Leute es kann sein dass ich euch jetzt im übelst misst erzähle ich habe mich mit wlan sachen nie so im detaill beschäftigt
es gibt doch irgendwie die diese beam forming geschichten dass so quasi die
polarisierung der der wlan
Wellen quasi in die richtung wo das gerät sich befindet ausgerichtet wird
seit wifi 6
Also man kann simpel sagen dass die antennen in die richtung vom gerät zeigen was nicht wirklich stimmt aber so kann man sich das vorstellen
und
Das können die beispielsweise auch schon ganz lange ja die dinger können kein wifi 6 ich habe die älteren die können nur wifi 5 was aber
auch vollkommen ausreicht
Und das geht auch wunderbar also ich habe super empfangen also auch auf der terrasse und überall
Ja so sieht es aus
Wie viele meetings hast du pro woche vor alter ich hatte am dienstag drei überlagerte meetings
Also
Eigentlich ist es ist fast jeder tag sehr viel gemiete
Einfach zeigen wie gut armen nutzbar ist ich glaube dass alleine überzeugt aber noch keinen armen server zu kaufen oder
Wenn du nur das gleiche machen kannst du x86 was juckt sich mein stromverbrauch
Juckt dich nicht weil du musst den stromverbrauch aber nicht bezahlen
Ja was juckt dich effizienz wenn du dir den server mietest du musst ja nicht bezahlen also mein natürlich ist es den preis irgendwie mit drinnen
Aber wenn sich wenn sich bin ich billiger ist
Wo haben die das denn hetzer cloud lasst mal kurz gucken
Am server preise
Ok kommen wir mal vielleicht ist er billiger
Ok es ist tatsächlich ein bisschen billiger
Es ist tatsächlich ein bisschen billiger man bekommt man bekommt mehr ram
Das ist ein cpu kann es ja nicht wirklich cpu kann man ja nicht wirklich vergleichen ja
Der ram ist in dem fall das interessante würde ich sagen also die erste kiste mit mit 8 gigabyte
Ram und was ist das erste vier also die erste kiste hier x86 mit 4 gigabyte ram
Kostet 6 37 und hier sind es
452 wir können es mal mit ip ip 4 4 ausmachen weil man braucht ja nicht wirklich eine publik ip 4 4 adresse
Für die meisten sachen reicht ja wenn man einen eingang hat
Ja cpu leistung ist jetzt so ein bisschen schwierig zu vergleichen weil ganz im ernst
zwei zwei
cores arm
Ich würde man pauschal von ausgehen dass die dual core x86 kiste immer noch rein cpu performance hier
Ich weiß ja nicht was die haben ich glaube die haben
reisen cpus amd und und und intel gemischt ja ich würde davon ausgehen dass sie sehr was sind ja
Keine billig cpus ja dass die
Reihen von der cpu anzahl und so immer noch besser sind als die armen cpus aber oftmals ist es ja so man braucht die fette
cpu leistung gar nicht
Also
Jetzt mal ernsthaft leute wer von euch hatte mal wer von euch hat schon mal eine vm
irgendwo gemietet
Muss jetzt ja auch nicht irgendwie klaut vm sein kann auch kann auch das wo man sich früher einen v server gekauft hat ist ja
Im prinzip auch kein unterschied nur dass es sich hier klaut nennt wer von euch hat schon mal sich ein klaut server gemietet einen virtuellen klaut
server gemietet und
Also das die erste frage und die zweite ist so voll ab frage follow-up frage
Ich gehe davon ich gehe von aus dass es also die server gemietet haben sich wahrscheinlich schon viele von euch
Und wer von euch hatte hat das ding zum größten teil cpu technisch ausgelastet
Also ich habe schon ich habe einige vms aktuell
Also privat ich rede jetzt nicht von auf der arbeit oder aber da habe ich natürlich noch ein bisschen mehr
privat
Aber ich glaube cpu technisch wirklich eine hohe auslastung haben die haben die wenigsten
Das ich weiß die vm von mir die am höchsten ausgelastet waren waren tatsächlich
Mal eine zeit lang die preis champ crawler die habe ich nämlich den ganzen tag crawlen lassen und das hat immer so
40 40 prozent cpu last
Verursacht das ist schon viel
Ja meine kisten hier daheim daheim eilen sich ein ab aber gut da muss ich auch den strom bezahlen
Kleinst der ovh server was mich bei ovh genervt hat ist dass sie kopierformen ausweis wollen ja vielleicht marks mark vielleicht
vorschrift sein aber
Kein bock mein ausweis ein zu skinn
Ja aber ram ram hat man öfters mal probleme also
Je nachdem was man was man macht ist ram halt mal relativ schnell weg aber cpu
Ja kommt drauf an was man macht zumindest ist es ist es eine interessante option zu sagen okay man spart ein bisschen geld
Bekommt dafür das doppelte ram ja wenn man mit der cpu auskommt
Ob die dinger jetzt mehr strom sparen oder nicht ist ja für mich also
Umwelttechnisch außen vor aber für mich beim
Monats betrag ja egal ich sehe das was ich im monat bezahle klar sind die strompreise damit eingerechnet aber
Es ist mir egal also wenn der preis für wenn der preis okay ist
Dann juckt mich nicht ob das effizienter ist als das
Ich muss gucken was ich hier was ich hier brauche ansonsten ich sehe ehrlich gesagt aber nur bis jetzt auf ein bisschen billiger
für beim ram
Ich sehe noch nicht so den großen vorteil ehrlich gesagt von den arm kisten
Und
Weil was
Gucken wir mal hier gibt es für 28 okay genau hier gibt es 28 55 16 kerne
32 g ram ok hier kriegt das ist natürlich schon mal eine ansage
Das ist natürlich schon mal eine ansage
Ehrlich gesagt würde ich es eher hiermit vergleichen weil also 16 16 amd kerne
Dürften 16 arm kerne lockerst in die tasche stecken
Wo hetzner sponsor aktuell gar nicht mehr also es ist glaube ich noch nicht mal mehr mein ref link gültig
Für hetzner registrierung habe auch schon eine weile nicht mal mit der marketing abteilung oder mit dem marketing team da geschrieben
Ich habe überlegt man könnte vielleicht was zur
Zu den armen cpus machen aber ich habe keine gute idee dafür
Ja
Aber das hier finde ich schon mal ganz gut
32 g ram kosten hier 38 56
Und hier bezahlste 10 euro weniger das finde ich ist eine gute sache also wenn du
Multi multi core leistung irgendwie brauchst und ordentlich ram
Warum nicht das hier wäre so ein ding wo ich sagen wird dass also das hier vielleicht mit acht oder mit 16 kerne das ist so ein
typisches ding wo ich sagen würde wenn man selbst
Sagen wir mal irgendwie
Triple node kubernetes cluster betreiben will oder sowas weil ich das ehrlich gesagt gar nicht mal so bedingt jetzt
Wahrscheinlich würde ich es nicht hier machen aber noch mal für den fall der fälle da wäre das natürlich was was richtig nice ist ja hier
So ein 16 kerne das blöde ist nur halt
Gehen deine sachen auf armen aber die meisten sachen gehen ja mittlerweile auf armen cpus
Also so einen so einen triple so einen triple node aus sowas hier da hast du genug ram hast du ordentlich
cpu leistung da kannst du schon einiges drauf raus drauf drauf laufen lassen
Du brauchst ja die passende anwendung führen einfach nur einfach nur das anlegen und sich dann freuen da bringt ja auch nichts
Also brauchst schon in der in der anwendung die du als eine in dem in den was in den web service ja den du anbietest
Wo du auch mit ordentlich vielen usern rechnest web services bieten sich an die lassen sich immer ziemlich gut parallelisieren
Ja das könnte man machen aber wie gesagt ich bin eh kein großer freund mittlerweile mehr von kubernetes selbst betreiben
Wer klar wenn es günstig sein soll kann man das machen aber wenn es günstig sein soll es gibt auch günstige kubernetes
haustik also digital außen zum beispiel ist kostet die hälfte von einem aks cluster
Wenn ich es richtig im kopf habe war die tisch und es gibt bestimmt noch günstigere ganz gute anbieter für haustät kubernetes
als als digital außen
Er kommt proxmox mit arm klar weiß ich gar nicht wahrscheinlich oder
Okay, okay gibt es nicht
Dort net anwendung auf arm kompilieren ja aber das ist ja kein kein spannendes beispiel
Also wir können tatsächlich
Also wir können tatsächlich also wir könnten das machen das könnte ich das das finde ich sogar eine gute idee
Wir könnten in kubernetes klassen
auf arm basis
Aber das ist auch keine gute demonstration warum warum abends eben warum er nähe ich mein
Das könnte ich genauso gut auf x86 kisten machen
Also also wozu auf der anderen seite vielleicht könnte man an der stelle eben
Bewerben dass es halt zehn euro billiger ist oder hier sogar oder hier sogar
So gar hier ist ein bisschen weniger dass halt deutlich günstiger ist wenn man
den ram brauche
Sowas geht auf arm ja das ist das ist aber doch keine das ist doch keine möglichkeit so für so was für den cloud anbieter ist
Ich kann doch kann ich pika vm zeigen für den cloud anbieter das passt ja überhaupt nicht zusammen
Du musst einen workload finden der besser ist auf 16 armen als auf acht normalen kern ja
Ideen chat
Ideen es muss irgendwas sein was sich super nice parallelisieren lässt und 16 16 kerne ausnutzt
Fragt gpt 4 gute idee linux bildserver
Ich weiß nicht überzeugt mich alles noch nicht so richtig
Wir müssen doch bilder von vom rack man angucken fällt mir gerade ein denn du darf dankeschön für den sub dazu kann ich nur sagen
Das ist übrigens das was der was der patrick gesucht hat an datenbanken hier hat geschrieben er hat ein cd tool welches für
bauteile in einer datenbank
Bauteile in einer datenbank abgelegt werden damit mehrere leute damit arbeiten können muss es eine zentrale datenbank geben
Gleichzeitig soll man aber auch offline lokal auf seinem pc arbeiten können also das ist ein zentrales datenbanken
Gleichzeitig soll man aber auch offline lokal auf seinem pc arbeiten können also muss da eine gruppie der tb sein gibt es
Irgendetwas schlaus das multimaster replication kann bei dem man manche tbs auch zwischendurch offline sind da konnte ich eben echt nichts dazu sagen
Ich persönlich hätte jetzt gedacht vielleicht gibt es die möglichkeit lokal was zu nehmen um das dann zu sünken also vielleicht gibt es
Irgendwie sowas wie ein ein
Eskült sinkt zu oder sowas aber das ist ja alles nicht der weisheitsletzter schluss
Macht doch eine web anwendung draus da ist das einfacher
Da kannst du da kannst du index db benutzen und die dann irgendwo hinsunken aber du willst wahrscheinlich keine elektron anwendung aus deinem cd tool machen oder
Ich bin
Kann netgear kann netgear business ap ist können die dps kam
Ok kegstuße fragt was wenn ich meine vm starte kommt eine fehlermeldung ich weiß auch woran es liegt ich muss
svm mode in was für ein ding
Was ist svm mode habe ich noch nie gehört
svm mode
ja
was bewirkt svm mode
Ach das ist das gegenstück zu vtx von amd
Ok na das ok
Allerdings habe ich gelesen das habe ich doch schon
Da habe ich das nicht schon längst beantwortet vor das habe ich auch vorhin schon beantwortet
Allerdings habe ich gelesen dass wenn ich das aktiviere würde meine performance vom pc darunter leiden
Also ich weiß nicht wie es bei amd ist aber ich würde es sehr wundern wenn deine performance vom pc darunter leidet
Ich würde mal sagen nee
Was du nicht machen solltest ist in windows 11 falls du windows 11 benutzt diese
Diese virtualisierungsgeschichten einschalten
Weil dann geht vor allem bei workstation nicht mal gescheit und windows spakt rum es gibt so eine
Wenn du wenn du virtualisierung im bios aktiviert hast schlägt dir windows vor
Wo ist denn seq windows security
Dann schlägt dir windows vor irgendwelche komischen dinger zu aktiv warum ist denn das aus was sind das schon wieder
Was ist das das vielleicht
Nee, okay, local security authority protection ist off
War das schon immer oft was ist das überhaupt
Ok, wenn das keine ahnung zumindest zumindest bietet ihr windows irgendwelche sachen an wenn ihr die
Das bietet ihr windows irgendwelche sachen an wenn du virtualisierung an hast dass die
Dass die irgendwelche software standardmäßig in hyper wie virtualisierung laufen also das würde ich nicht machen
Weil dann hast du da hast du problemen das könnte auch was langsamer machen aber einfach nur dass im bios einschalten sollte keine probleme machen
Also mich würde es sehr wundern wenn es probleme machen sollte ich habe das auch an also ich habe auch alles alles aktiviert
für virtualisierung
Gut ich habe auch in 13.000 13.900 k und spiele eigentlich gar nichts wirklich leistungsfähiges zur zeit aber ok
Haben ich wollte es auch haben hauptsächlich
Die katze ist an der tür sekunde ich muss
Die katze ist da
Hast du manchmal so aufgaben die schon wieder eine weile ruhen und immer wenn es da was neues zu tun gibt du einfach schmerzempfindest
Müsste ich mir mal gedanken darüber machen also beim neuen jetzt will die katze wieder raus
Die katze hat sie mich richtig richtig gebatet nicht die hier aber ich habe gerade keine andre sie maus
Also beim aktuellen beim aktuellen arbeitgeber noch nicht
Beim alten hatte ich da welche
Beim alten hatte ich welche ja ich war zu ich war zuständig
Also beim alten arbeitgeber war ich zuständig für so ein paar äscher vm's
Die
Wollte ich eigentlich nie betreuen und der weg wie die zu mir gekommen sind ist immer noch ziemlicher pains champ ich habe mich nämlich mal beschwert
oder was heißt beschwert ja ich habe mal was vorgestellt auf der alten arbeit und zwar dass es schwierig ist ich
Ich will es euch jetzt ich muss es gar nicht so sehr im detail erzählen lange rede kurzer sinn
Ich habe was präsentiert und auf eine problematik hingewiesen mit diesen vm's
Und ich habe mich dann auch in der in der fragerunde danach dazu bereit erklärt wenn es neue
Ja, änderungen bei diesen vm's gibt sie mal auszuprobieren
Ob damit meine bedenken quasi aus der welt geschafft sind so und was dann irgendwie wie das ganze dann gelaufen ist
Eines der gründe auch mit warum ich bei dem alten arbeitgeber weg bin weil so sachen dort gerne so gelaufen sind
Dadurch dass ich es angesprochen habe
Sollte ich es dann irgendwann auch machen
Und ich wollte nicht und ich habe immer gesagt das mache ich nicht das ist nicht meine aufgabe ich habe nur drauf hingewiesen dass das und
Das nicht ordentlich funktioniert das heißt nicht
Dass ich das jetzt admin technisch an der backe haben will aus dem gehört das überhaupt nicht zu mir
Ich habe da auch meistens keinen handschlag dran gemacht ja und oftmals kamen dann immer leute zu mir und haben gesagt du hast doch
Damit was zu tun dann musste ich ihnen immer erklären nein ich habe nichts damit zu tun
Ich habe nur gesagt es funktioniert nicht ordentlich und ja du willst mich jetzt darauf hinweisen es funktioniert nicht ordentlich ich weiß
Darauf habe ich hingewiesen dass ich ordentlich funktioniert
So und das das war schon ziemlich painstamp beim neuen arbeitgeber habe ich sowas noch nicht
Weil über kurz oder lang gibt es natürlich sowas immer mal wieder
Aber das ist in der zweiten wochen das wäre blöd wenn ich sowas schon in der zweiten woche hätte oder
Video decoding oder nkw video encoding aber video encoding ist jetzt auch was was
Wahrscheinlich auf den abend cpus nicht schneller macht
selbst wenn ein paar mehr hast
Kleinstell vor ha so ok das gucken wir uns noch mal schnell an o4
Reißing reißing
Ok halb halb vor die seite ok das hat verweistung da habe ich auch mal nette genau durchgeblickt
Also was haben die denn oh die machen hier ein auf amazon benahmung oder besser gesagt microsoft benahmung ein bisschen
M
Manf
Wo kostest du 96 cent
Ich sehe da nicht 96 cent wo muss ich denn gucken das da
Hier 97 cent
Was sind der unterschied zwischen einer cloud vm und einer cloud vm
Moment ah ok ok hier kommen das sachen näher open stack von ks
Also die art ist moment das erste jahr und dann und dann
Und dann 4 20 und dann kostet 4 euro 20 das nächste jahr
Ja dann ist das ja auch nicht so toll also ich habe noch bei
Ich habe seit ein paar jahren so eine ein ein euro vm im jahr nicht im jahr was laber ich denn
Ein euro im monat vm
Bei
Was war das denn es war nicht strato
ionos ionos genau die habe ich mir vor
Der ganzen weile mal gekauft weil ich mir dachte ich für ein mo ein ein euro den monat
Der ganzen weile mal gekauft weil ich mir dachte ich für ein mo ein ein euro den monat kannst du nichts verkehrt machen und bis jetzt
Funktionen das auch ganz gut
Danach ist auch nicht billiger als beispielsweise bei jetzt
Aber kann man bestimmt machen also von denen habe ich auch viel gutes gehört das ist schon denke ich ganz guter anbieter
Bei ovh sind die vms und server on fire und der witz hat jetzt auch schon so ein bad oder
Also für ich erkläre das mal was er meint ist
Vielleicht haben sie nicht alle mitbekommen aber bei denen hat man recht bei denen ich mal vor nicht allzu langer zeit in rechenzentrum abgefackelt
Und hatten sie tagelang probleme
und
Bin zurzeit unsicher ob ich die richtige umschulung mache bekomme einfach keinen praktikumsplatz mache kaufmann für e-commerce
Der kaufmann ist schon das erste problem
Da kann ich dir nichts zu raten ich habe auch mal was mit kaufmann gemacht
Oder versucht versucht
Oder hatte kein bock mehr drauf ist aber schon ganz ganz lang her
Die pt4 ist nicht schlauer als wir das wundert mich nicht der chat hier ist ja auch absolut high iq
Hast du für selbst gehostete kubernetes cluster
ok
Ne habe ich nicht und ich habe auch kein selbst gehosteten kubernetes cluster
Ich habe es auch nicht vor denn bei mir lokal wüsste ich nicht was ich mit einem selbst gehosteten kubernetes cluster anfangen soll
Oder die vorteile von werden
Und bei irgendwelchen cloud anbietern mit eigenen cluster bauen sehe ich auch keinen sinn weil ich habe keine public anwendung wo sich das
Irgendwie rentieren würde so was zu betreiben und für die paar sachen die ich laufen habe
Zum beispiel mein location tracking fürs handy und sowas was dann an meine heim automatisierung schickt
Es ist ein prozess auf einer vm das muss nicht kubernetes cluster laufen
Was hältst du von consultants oder habe ich mich heute schon genug darüber ausgelassen
Die
Katze fbs die die eben da war ist nicht die hier das ist das ist die ganz alte katze fbs die gibt es aber nicht mehr
die original katze fbs
Die aber die jetzt die jetzige ist auch ganz schön alt schon ja ich habe eigentlich nur alte katzen
Aber warum auch nicht
Das ist auch absicht das ist auch absicht also gerade die letzten zwei die ich aus dem tierheim geholt habe
Das war absicht dass das alte sind gerade alte katzen wollen viele nicht
Und ich meine alte katzen sind ja also ab sieben ab sieben jahre gilt eine katze als alt die katzen werden heute
25 plus teilweise alle aber
Das ist durchaus möglich wenn ihnen wenn die die frühen jahre als freigänger
Überlebt zum beispiel ist die chance dass sie älter werden richtig hoch mittlerweile mit
ordentliche ernährung mit
Keine straße oder sowas und regelmäßig auch beim tierarzt gucken das impon passen und so was ist mittlerweile kein ding
Katzen können relativ alt werden
Ich hoffe natürlich auch dass meine alt werden
Ich durfte jetzt 13 oder so sein
Oder 14 vielleicht und 13 13
Ist auch schon bisschen älter ja
Das stimmt jetzt das noch
Aber eine vm bei strato nur nx plus nex laus drauf kam ich konnte
Ja gut bei der ein euro vm würde ich ehrlich gesagt mich nicht
Beschwerden wenn das da nicht drauf läuft
Ich glaube ich auch schon ein bisschen ressourcen hungrig
Ja
Ja aber die kosten auch mehr
Hast du tipps für die abschlussprüfung als fisi ja den einzigen tipp den ich dir geben kann ist mache alte prüfung
Ja
Und woher weißt du das war die gechipt oder was
Oder woher weißt du das
Pfeifert
Ach man kann den chat ach du zeichnest den chat ja irgendwie
Auf oder so okay nice nice
So wir müssen uns jetzt noch eine sache angucken nämlich die pepo bilder
Die sind richtig nice das kann ich soviel kann ich euch schon sagen sind richtig
Way zu dank guckt euch die mal an sind die nicht nice
Komm was was wir jetzt hier alles haben also wir haben den wir haben den pepo beim mittagessen
Echt richtig also quasi
Wir haben den pepo beim mittagessen
Dann haben wir den den kennen wir schon keks essen
Beim arbeiten
Dann einfach normal
Dann ist den google so lahm dann mit t oder kaffee kann man sich aussuchen dann t kaffee und
Poggers
Cousins
Dann mit t im java style beim wenn wenn
Sonnenaufgang
Dann haben wir beim frühstücken nach dem sonnenaufgang mit mühsli natürlich was sonst
Mit mühsli sondern haben wir das ganze auch mal mit croissants und dem und dem t der dampft
So als nächstes haben wir den sleep pepe der träumt es
Was ist der unterschied ach ach guck mal da einmal mit mond
Einmal mit mond und einmal ohne
Das dürfte natürlich nicht fehlen
Mit mond und ohne ok so er träumt von linux er träumt was kommt als nächstes
Er träumt vom pepo grill
Wahrscheinlich wieder mit mond und ohne
Er träumt von pepo grill
Wahrscheinlich wieder mit mond und ohne er träumt von pap
So er ist es einfach nur einfach nacht er schläft
Hier ist er hier wird man wach nachts ist auch nicht verkehrt hier schläft er
So
Sonnenaufgang ne sonnenuntergang ist das sonnenuntergang sonnenuntergang zähne putzen
Nochmal sonnenuntergang das ist sunrise das ist sunset ok
Ja
Dann guckt er abends den ultra skiller an das ist übrigens auch sehr schön vom winkel das könnte so halbwegs passen dass er das
sich so anguckt
Guckt auf den beamer
Nice oder da ich glaube wir haben für den kompletten tag jetzt pepo bilder
Wie kann man die wallpaper runterladen noch gar nicht die muss ich euch mal irgendwo bereit stellen
Also ich habe mir das so gedacht ich mache mir die als hintergrund in die vm
Und dann stellen wir nach vm ein dass das halt je nach uhrzeit die wallpaper abdeckt die gibt es bei mir im gitt
Also wenn der rechner nix dagegen hat
Ich würde die einfach in in mein git repo hauen zu den anderen dot files
Man könnte natürlich auch den google folder den google drive folder noch verlinken
Simple bashtrip to set wallpaper according to current time ja genau so was brauche das ist
Das ist tatsächlich ganz praktisch sowas hier
Sowas hier und ist auch nicht lang 244 244 zeilen beschript
Ja
Ja okay leute eigentlich wollte ich heute nicht nur laba stream machen aber auf was anderes
Ging heute nicht mehr muss jetzt pennen morgen wieder arbeiten wir sehen uns macht es gut bis morgen